technology has always been deflationary
from from the invention of the wheel to
to everything we do it's it's our ideas
put into things or technology that makes
our lives better right and that that
reduces the labor component and remote
uh or or today in a lot of cases removes
the labor component
and so
but it used to happen if you go back to
Roman times it used to happen over a
slower period
and but because we always had hard money
um but hard money couldn't gain velocity
so you could we couldn't have fast
enough velocity to do global trade in in
Gold you had to have a credit Market
built on top to build a and and that
credit Market once it built on top and
sends the system to expand product
and and reduce the amount of gold in a
system
and at the end of that bubble Ray dalio
talks about this at the end of that
bubble the debt can't be repaid back so
governments always either seize the gold
or they they start driving more and more
inflation and a function of that whole
model is we we believe it today is two
percent inflation is required for a
productive economy and it's a false
construct we believe it though so it's
real for us and it's it's a it is a
construct if you have to build a debt
bubble that has to keep growing and then
eventually that depth bubble has to turn
into eight percent inflation fourteen
fifty percent inflation it has to
um
and and so what that meant is in the
Roman times
uh you would have a currency failure
every five or six hundred years
and then as you advance through history
as technology is moving more and more
moving faster and faster you had debt
Bubbles and those not not the small ones
the massive debt bubbles that kind of
tends to take countries to war
um every 100 years
and today you have them
if you project what actually would
happen you would have them every 50
years remember the U.S defaulted on
their debt in 1971. and and so now the
petrodollar is is effectively defaulting
now and so you have them every 50 years
and that all of those things are caused
by technology moving faster and faster
and faster and it's moving so and we're
projecting
backwards all of our all of what we
think looks backwards instead of looking
forwards if you look forward on the
technology access axis is moving at a
rate we can't even comprehend so that
exponential rate of Technology now
moving forward means if you run a
monetary policy that requires inflation
it means you have to collapse you have
these debt bubbles in a faster and
faster rate
and that's where bitcoin's so different
you gain monetary velocity through the
network you can have unlimited monetary
velocity without creating a massive debt
bubble on on top and so people think oh
it has to act like gold
it doesn't act like gold you can I can
trade we can trade Bitcoin over and over
again India to to uh to El Salvador to
Canada to hear all an instant
transaction transactions on on lightning
and and and it's it so you don't have to
store gold in a vault built up monetary
and go back and forth on it on slow
rails that change changes the very
nature of debt markets and it changes
the very nature of how things move and
allow technology to create abundance for
all of us actually yeah hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time